après les élections municipales de mars
et de juin 2020 qui ont été marquées par
un taux d'abstention record
françois bayrou a souhaité que nous
ouvrions un grand chantier sur les
causes de l'abstention et sur les moyens
de renforcer la participation électorale
ce grand chantier c'est un groupe de
travail c'est une consultation citoyenne
qui a rassemblé plusieurs milliers de
contributeurs et ce sont de nombreuses
auditions qui ont été menées aujourd'hui
nous vous en livrons les résultats au
mouvement démocrate nous considérons que
les causes profondes de l'abstention
réside dans l'offre politique et sa
capacité à représenter l'ensemble des
sensibilités qui traverse le pays mais
aussi dans la facilité qui est donnée à
chacune et à chacun d'entre nous
d'exprimer notre vote le jour j alors de
quelle manière
renforcer la participation électorale
rang dont l'inscription sur les listes
plus automatique
trop de français sont inscrits dans des
communes dans lesquelles ils ne résident
pas en instaurant la proportionnelle qui
a le mérite de représenter plus
largement les sensibilités du pays en
mettant en place le vote à distance qui
nous permettra de voter quelles que
soient les circonstances en éveillant
les consciences aussi des citoyens dès
leur plus jeune âge et puis enfin en
facilitant l'accès des personnes les
plus fragiles
au bureau de vote de manière à ce que
chacun puisse apporter sa voix au
mouvement démocrate
nous considérons que la france peut
traverser les crises sans avoir à mettre
la démocratie à l'arrêt le moment est
donc venu de moderniser nos procédures
électorales